hola estamos en donde un toro está aquí
en octubre celebramos el mes de la
hispanidad a acompañarme aquí a la
galería
[Aplausos]
[Música]
aquí celebramos nuestra posición que se
llama gracias a la vida y es un homenaje
a la canción de violeta parra que es muy
popular
muchísimas nosotros conocemos la letra
mire para las obras que tenemos
justamente el 4 de octubre se celebrarán
los 100 años del nacimiento de violeta
parra
por eso queríamos darle ese título a
esta exposición donde en realidad
agradecemos
y nosotros todos como latinos
no entendemos con esa misma letra a la
solidaridad y la humildad qué significa
tener tantas cosas buenas en la vida
aquí estamos méxico colombia guatemala
está chile perú ecuador uruguay y
venezuela todos llegamos aquí con
diferentes motivaciones y todos tenemos
nuestro propio estilo aquí voy a
encontrar desde pura extracción hasta
tenemos más tradicionales tenemos cosas
con temporales y tenemos trabajos que
son bien cerca del del costumbrismo y el
folclor es una exposición muy rica todos
los cuadros tienen colores brillantes
este más impactantes es muy lindo que lo
podemos compartir en el opening tuvimos
la oportunidad también de tener la
gastronomía es compartir gastronomía
literatura música latinoamericana en
realidad es una muy rica representación
de la cultura que nosotros podemos
ofrecer aquí en toronto los artistas que
participamos en esta exhibición es una
reunión de 31 personas que fuimos
principalmente invitados por alexis
jovino un artista
que gracias a su amistad y su
colaboración con carlos alsina de la
galería art óseas aquí en toronto
lograron esta exhibición lograron que
nos reuniéramos todo aquí tenemos más de
60 obras creo que es un total de 70 obra
porque estos 31 artistas que vienen de
diferentes países
piensas que bien queremos agradecer
nosotros como inmigrantes la oportunidad
que nos ha dado este país nos ha abierto
las puertas para desarrollarnos como
personas y además nos ha dado la
oportunidad de expresar nuestra pasión
en este caso que es las artes visuales y
contribuir de esa manera es con el
recrecimiento lo que nosotros
pretendemos es el enriquecimiento de
nuestra comunidad
a tus jazz le da la bienvenida aquí en
el 16 84 saint pierre
avn y west en el downtown pronto y por
favor no se pierdan la oportunidad de
visitar esta exhibición que de verdad
está muy completa